[Music]
morning
everyone it is seven o'clock in the uk
welcome wherever you're watching us
around the world this morning new set of
traffic lights summer holidays are back
on the horizon
bought with a note of caution with
holiday islands put on a new green
watch list that could see them switch to
amber
we'll ask the transport secretary grant
chaps about that in just a moment
and the new travel freedom's heading for
some but only if you've had two jabs
we'll speak to the boss of ryanair as
airlines rush to put on
extra flights with some accused of
ramping up prices
[Music]
i know i was trying not to do that as
well i will go live to the real life
club tropicana preparing to welcome back
british holidaymakers to ibiza
we'll speak to the creative director of
the ubita rocks hotel
[Music]
one britain one nation will talk to the
former police officer
who wants all schools to learn shared
values of kindness and respect through
the medium
of music it's friday the 25th of june
green light but a warning the holiday
islands that have just been made
quarantined free travel destinations
are at risk of moving from green to
amber
grab a jab football stadia theaters and
supermarkets become
walk-in centers as anyone over the age
of 18
can now get a vaccine without
i booking about the cases going up um
massively in the uk and
so on that side i worry for people a bit
premature why lewis hamilton is
concerned about a full house at the
british grand prix
a survivor is pulled from the rubble of
a collapsed apartment building in miami
as president biden declares a state of
emergency
we'll be live in miami as families wait
for news about the
99 people still missing
the blood test that can detect 50 types
of cancer to be trialled by the nhs
and a much colder day across northern
areas with spells of rain brighter
and warmer in the south but also some
heavy showers i'll have the details for
you
later
[Music]
good morning everybody this friday
morning summer holidays
may be back on but there's a warning
this morning over the holiday islands
that have been
added to the green travel list malta the
balearic islands
and a number of caribbean destinations
such as barbados
have been put on a green watch list
which the government says means
they're at risk of switching from green
to amber so people should take
extra care when thinking about traveling
to those holiday hotspots
plans too to give people who've had two
jabs more freedoms
so the government says it plans to allow
fully vaccinated people in england to
travel to an ambulance country
without having to quarantine on their
return by later
this summer malta madeira and spain's
baleric islands
make up the european countries to be
added to the green
travel watch list a number of caribbean
islands including
antigua barbados grenade grenada have
also been added along with
other overseas uk territories including
anguia
bermuda and the cayman islands as laura
bondock reports
wish you were here you could be very
soon
the balearic beaches are back on the
green list
and that's what aina and her much missed
majorcan family
hope to hear so relieved it's amazing
my daughter you might hear her but she
is jumping up and down
on on her bed so it looks like
the ceiling might fall um it is a huge
relief it means
um it just it it feels almost
like it's over and there's more good
news for holiday hopefuls
the government says the double
vaccinated will have extra travel
freedoms
but we don't know when
no decisions until next month leaving
the travel industry
once more in limbo certainty is really
important we know from talking to our
customers
they're just confused they're worried
they're nervous
and they just want that certainty that
if they book something they will be able
to travel
and it's going to take a little bit of
time to get there but the more that the
government can do
to create that certainty the better most
of the new green list countries have
been added to the green
watch list that means they're at risk of
being downgraded
and that makes booking a getaway a
gamble
with the current variant being quite
high i just feel that it's probably not
safe i personally wouldn't travel yet
not probably till next year
since there's very little risk if you're
double jabbed
from what i understand either of you're
getting sick or if you're infecting
somebody else
you should be able to travel and no
quarantine i think you just have to
listen to what the government have got
to say
presumably they've got good data the
trouble is the data changes
and that's why some feel we should hold
off foreign holidays
the delta variants ticking off in a big
way of course in the uk
and it's now showing real problems
across europe
my view is that this is a summer where
we probably should stay at home where
international travel should be kept to a
minimum and i think we'll be in a much
much a better place come the autumn and
certainly by next spring
our airports are quiet and there remain
lots of questions about mass travel this
summer
are we nearly there yet the answer
simply
no laura bundock sky news
transport strategy grant shaps is with
us now mr shaps you get the badge for
the most popular minister
this morning why these countries in
particular
uh well we took the scientific advice of
the joint biosecurity center
um they said these are the countries
which could now be moved to the
green list that means that you can
travel there
uh be aware there are still some things
you'll need to do you'll still need to
test when you come home for example
but it does mean that there's a little
bit of relief
as you mentioned in that report for the
travel industry and of course for people
who wish to get away but it won't be
quite like it was in the
2019 in the old days but we're a move in
positive direction
okay belaric's and madeira though are on
the watch list amongst others the green
watch list i mean you more than most
will
know what it's like to get somewhere and
then immediately have to
come back and and quarantine um would
you book a holiday to majorca
at the moment yes i should just explain
the the watch list the green watch list
it means they're on the green list it
means you can go
uh it's treated like a a green list but
we're just being completely open with
the data that the scientists have given
us and say
in saying there are one two concerns it
might mean that we're
we have to perhaps respond quickly on
there so we've said it's the green
watch list in order that people can see
exactly what we're seeing
uh about it and i do i have to say
whoever is booking
and to go anywhere this summer at all
you know travel insurance making sure
your flights are changeable
and making sure the accommodations
change but all those things are going to
be very very important this particular
year
and i think you know people need to
weigh up whether that is
going to be work for them or not yeah
because i mean we saw what happened with
portugal though didn't we and that was
on the green
liz the watch list and that's flipped uh
in a heartbeat so that my question again
is
would you book a holiday for your family
to one of the balearic islands at the
moment given that it's on a watch list
yeah so actually they were just on the
green um list and the reason we've
introduced the using this watchlist
category is to give people a bit more
visibility
over it if we think things might move uh
quicker um so
sadly i don't think i've got time at the
moment to take a holiday
um but um you know if people are in a
situation where
uh from next week next wednesday
thursday
they wanted to get away then this these
are the places
where you can go for the purposes of of
holiday of course being aware of all the
uh caveats about the the risk of things
changing because
in this virus we know that happens with
quite a lot of regularity
i know you're impossibly busy and we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us but would you book a holiday to
majorca if you were less busy at the
moment
well as i say i you're asking me if i if
i was in someone else's shoes
and i'm not i i'm not looking to go on
holiday right this moment um
because i'm i'm rather busy dealing with
this and a lot of other transport issues
um but so each individual will look at
their own situation i'm not trying to
fudge a question
each individual will look at their own
situation and
people have flexibility then that
obviously is going to be a bit easier
this year
uh if people want um you know more
authority there are uh there are some
although limited number of locations
which are just on the green list
they don't have the watch list list tag
uh
after it people will have to come to
their own decisions and i think most
people realize that after having gone
through coronavirus for
what is now the second full summer
angela merkel's not your best friend at
the moment issue she wants all uk
visitors to quarantine when they arrive
in the eu
no look i understand that germany
doesn't have the same level of
uh vaccinations as has happened in this
country
so they'll be particularly uh concerned
each country will have to come to their
own decision
a country like malta which has a very
high level of vaccination
haven't said the same thing uh and other
european countries will come to their
own decisions and i think i respect that
that's for the for them to do
but it is different in each country and
largely driven by
levels of vaccination that they've
managed to achieve in each country
okay those that are lucky enough to have
had two jabs um
what sort of benefits might they be
expecting a little bit further down the
road
yeah that's the other thing i flagged up
yesterday which is we've met with
the scientists and we've discussed this
and we think that later in the summer
if you've had both vaccinations then we
may well be able to treat
a location which is currently an amber
in the middle there
this country as if it were a green list
country from the point of view of a
double or fully vaccinated
individual so that means you'll be able
to come back take the single test which
is what you have with the green
and not have to quarantine i
we need more information and data on
this and there are some difficult issues
to resolve as well
with regard to you know what happens for
example for children
for those who can't be vaccinated and of
course giving everybody the opportunity
to have those vaccinations
and if you're over 18 now please book
please go and have your
your your first job and get the second
one when you're called so
there are a number of things that needs
to happen first but i thought it was
right to give people an indication of
our sort of direction of travel
what we were seeing and what we think
might be possible
i'll say more about that next month okay
i mean i'm guessing that it would be
perfect to dovetail that into the 19th
of july terminus day wouldn't it
well i think it's unfortunately a bit
more complicated than that for example
we've got uk vaccination certificates
and if you download the regular nhs
app that's not the covered one that you
use to check in it's just the normal nhs
app
it will already it's already capable of
displaying your vaccine certificate
it will show your vaccine status um so
that's easy for people who have uk
vaccinations what do you do for example
for a country
that doesn't have any indication of
vaccination
status and i'm thinking here locations
where
uh for example the united states where i
think they probably have 50 different
systems and much of which is paper-based
in different states
so there are complications in terms of
how you would accept
other people's vaccination certification
and those are the things that we'll be
working through which i imagine will
take longer than the 19th of july
uh particularly for people traveling
from other countries here
so we'll we'll probably focus in phase
one
on uk vaccinated people who've been
double vaccinated
and what that means for their travel
into amber areas
okay so it's looking more like august
really isn't it
well i'd say i i you're you're
preempting something which i just don't
know the answer to and i won't be
completely upfront
with you about that not least because
the joint committee on vaccines and
immunizations
have yet to opine on whether children
should or shouldn't have vaccinations
for example and that's one of the very
big areas is
what do you do if children are not going
to be
getting vaccinations so there's quite a
lot of um
interrelated and complicated decisions
to make on this i thought it was right
just to give people
an indication and particularly the
travel sector an indication that we are
looking at this we are working with the
scientists on this and we're thinking
about
how we can best apply it and so just in
the interest of being
transparent about it we're we're telling
people uh what we're thinking about and
i'll come back next month and be able to
say more on it okay silverstone planning
a
capacity crowd for the british grand
prix lewis hamilton says he's worried
about his fans that are in the stands
why is he wrong to worry
well i think i i i just saw that story
before i came on i think that the most
important thing as with all of these
this experimental program where we've
been seeing
numbers of crowds being able to attend
events we need to follow the science
uh and see uh what that's saying so far
as i understand it um so good there are
tests done
before on these programs experimental
programs there are tests on a period
afterwards
to see what's happening and depending on
the the uh
environment what's happening so for
example obviously we know outdoor events
are much better than indoor
events for example from from the point
of view of not spreading the virus
so my simple answer is let's follow the
science
let's see what that says and then and
then uh be able to
uh open events uh as per uh the the
uh the opportunities to do so obviously
we all want to get back to the
uh the world we we used to live in we've
got to do so safely
okay got it um so he needs to worry not
uh 19th
of july uh george eustis when he was on
the show the other day
and i think rishi sunak as well has said
that they're going to ditch their mask
will you be doing the same well i should
say actually the government's carrying
out
a review of what to do with what are
called the non-pharmaceutical
measures uh that's things like social
distancing things like wearing masks and
the like
so i'm gonna wait to get the outcome of
that because again it will be based on
scientific information before i before i
uh sort of jump to
uh conclusions obviously we're all
desperate to sort of ditch the masks but
i think we want to wait for the science
first before making a decision
but there is no legal compunction to
where a mask is after the 19th of july
which is why he says he's
um certainly george eustis who i
interviewed said absolutely it's gone
yeah well look as i say i i the whole
point of setting up these reviews
following the scientific data is to be
able to advise people
as somebody i saw in the package you
paid just before i came on very wisely
said
let's wait and see what the technical
and scientific advice
that is let's wait to see what the
government recommends and then we'll be
able to make a decision
there are people who say they'll feel
more comfortable for example on on
on transport if they keep the mask on
other people say it should be removed
what i want to do is see what the
science says and make sure that we can
all
travel go about our business as safely
as possible bit more cautious then
uh now i need to ask you about the sun
story this morning about the health
secretary matt hancock
uh what are the rules about appointing
friends to a position
at the heart of government which may
give them special access
well first of all um i think the actual
issue is an entirely
personal um issue for uh for matt
hancock
um in terms of uh rules anyone who's
been appointed has to go through an
incredibly rigorous process in
in government um so whatever the rules
are the rules will have to be followed
there are no shortcutting uh that is
anyone who's had anything to do with the
appointment system in the civil service
knows uh there are very
strict uh rules in place yeah i mean the
we spoke to the department of health
this morning they said this appointment
was made in the usual way and followed
correct procedure what exactly also some
time ago
what is that procedure so uh it depends
on the
specific role um but people have to go
through usually an an interview process
which involves an independent panel
recommendations are then made to
ministers depending on the type of role
uh you'll get a
uh something called appointable or
non-appointable
list and then you make a decision based
on the qualifications of the
uh individual so i don't think um
i think it's a bit of a red herring in
in this case i think it's really a
personal
story and it's not so i don't intend to
comment on somebody else's
personal life i didn't ask you to um i
was just asking you about what the rules
were as far as appointing people was
concerned and i i suppose i would
ask you finally would you be comfortable
appointing
um a universe a former university friend
into your office
well i would only ever appoint somebody
who's qualified for the role
um as i understand it this individual
was more than qualified for the
for the role of advice was being
provided
as i say beyond that uh i i fear you
tend to be into
commenting on personal matters and uh
you know the health sects been working
very hard rolling out this vaccine uh
program uh and
uh so i'll leave it there yeah you was
trying to leave the witness there
and i certainly wasn't asking you that
mr schaps i just wanted to know what the
rules were
it's always good to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the program thank you
still to come on the program for you
speaking to the boss of one of europe's
biggest airlines michael o'leary from
ryanair
as european holiday hot spots are added
to the green list
the former chancellor george osborne
prepares to take over at the british
museum but should it hand back some of
its treasures from
other countries we'll discuss that at 7
45
and i'm going to be chatting to former
hollyoaks actor luke jody about his new
play
highlighting the ease with which young
men can turn to violence that's at half
past nine
really tragic news coming out of the u.s
this morning 99 people are still missing
after an apartment building collapsed in
miami in florida
at least one person has died in the
collapse yesterday morning the cause
still unclear excuse me
our u.s correspondent martha kelner
reports
this is what remains of a 12-story
apartment block on florida's atlantic
coast
it happened while they were sleeping at
1 30 a.m
people nearby thought it could have been
a piercing crack of thunder
the truth was far more traumatic a cctv
camera capturing the moment the building
came down
with no warning for the dozens of people
inside
apartment units ripped in two by the
force
lives torn apart sky news has been told
that a british woman
38 year old bhavna patel who is pregnant
is missing so too are her husband vishal
and one-year-old daughter aishani their
close friend is struggling to comprehend
what has happened to this family bob
noah's an angel she was a sweet kind
loving woman
they were they're just just god sent you
know and i guess god came back for his
angels
you know and i the kids so mine
there were 134 apartment units in this
building
more than half were destroyed hope was
briefly ignited
as this young boy was rescued from the
rubble by firefighters
who began work despite the risk of the
entire building collapsing
but unable to penetrate the debris from
above a rescue team took their efforts
below ground
battling conditions in a car park trying
to locate
any voids where survivors may be
rescuers
said at one point they heard a sound of
knocking from the wreckage
for the families here any news like that
is a glimmer of light on the darkest of
days
but this search is likely to be long and
for many here
utterly agonizing a local state of
emergency was declared here
as rescue teams continued through the
night sifting through the wreckage of a
building which housed many international
residents
sophia lopez marrera sister of
paraguay's first lady
and her husband are among the missing
this is a tragedy without precedent
in the united states of america
the devastation that that that i
witnessed today
is is the likes of which i've never seen
and i have been
to haiti and other other nations
it's a community of families retirees
and holidaymakers
the inquiry into why this building came
down with such devastating consequence
has already begun
martha's with us she's at a community
center in miami where families
are desperately waiting for the news
hello to you martha i can't begin to
imagine
how they must be feeling what's it like
then
it's fairly horrific to be honest kay
it's a scene of utter
desperation inside this community centre
in surf side
now surfside is a community which is
around six miles north of miami beach
which people at home
may be more familiar with south side as
the name
suggests is a place where the beach is
the focus of everyday life
and in fact i was speaking to a close
friend of bhavna patel the 38 year old
british woman
who you saw in that report who's missing
along with her husband and her
one-year-old daughter
their friend was telling me that bhavna
moved her young family
into the champlain towers apartment the
block that collapsed
because it had such a beautiful view of
the white sandy beach
and the atlantic ocean beyond never
could they have imagined
that they'd be at the centre of such a
tragedy
and bhavna's family are now in this
community centre behind me
it's been repurposed as a reunification
center
there's around 40 to 50 families and
friends
of the 99 people still unaccounted for
inside there waiting for news from the
search and rescue teams that search and
rescue operation
is still ongoing it's been hampered not
only by the difficult conditions above
ground and the huge debris
the flooding underneath ground where
they're trying to get up but also
the unpredictable florida weather in
june they're hoping
that daybreak brings better news and
possible survivors in that wreckage
okay martha thank you very much indeed
thanks
absolutely tragic um also coming up for
you
this morning hundreds of walk-in
vaccination sites will be operating this
weekend with all adults urged to turn up
and
grab a jab anyone aged 18 or over can
turn up at the sites which include
football stadia theatres
and supermarket car parks almost 32
million people in the uk have now
received both doses
of a coronavirus vaccine
scientists say a blood test that can
detect more than 50 types of cancer
before any clinical signs or symptoms
of the disease is accurate enough to be
rolled out as a screening test
the test which is due to be piloted by
nhs england is aimed at people at higher
risk of the disease such as patients
over 50. researchers found the test
correctly identified when cancer was
present in more than 51 percent of cases
across
all stages of the disease it wrongly
detected cancer in less than one percent
of cases
the test also identified the tissue in
which the cancer was located
in almost 90 percent of cases the nhs
pilot will involve 165
000 patients with the results expected
by 2023
experts have warned that a e departments
are being flooded with children with
often mild fevers creating a winter in
june for the nhs
as lockdown eases more children are
coming into contact with viruses usually
seen in the winter months
and now three royal colleges have issued
guidance for parents
after seeing a large rise in numbers
seeking emergency help
for conditions that are not covered
almost 600 million covey tests handed
out in england may have gone
unused the national audit office says 96
million
lateral flow tests have been registered
with nhs test and trace
just 14 of the 691 million distributed
the cost of test and trace was put at
13.5 billion pounds
by the last financial year
pop star britney spears has written on
social media about her efforts to
challenge a conservatorship
order she posted on instagram about the
case
24 hours after she told a judge the
order effectively forced her to work
the legal agreement has been in place
since 2008 with britney's father in
control
of her career and her finances brittany
decided to share this quote from
einstein if you want your children to be
intelligent
read them fairy tales if you want them
to be more intelligent
read them more fairy tales she also had
a message for her followers i just want
to tell you guys a little secret
i believe as people we all want the
fairy tale life
and by the way i've posted my life seems
to be and look
be pretty amazing
i also apologize for pretending like
i've been okay
the past two years i did it because of
my pride and i was embarrassed to share
what happened to me believe it or not
pretending that i'm
okay has actually helped so i decided
to post this quote today
time now for a look at the morning's
newspapers for you
and foreign holidays confusion deepens
the telegraph reports that ministers are
accused
of making summer travel more complex
the guardian says there's a cabinet rift
over plans to grant more travel freedoms
to those who have received both doses
of a coronavirus vaccine but the mail is
upbeat declaring that summer getaways
have been saved on its front page
the sun has a story about the health
secretary matt hancock
and the star reports on the diplomatic
standoff involving the royal navy
and russia near crimea on wednesday
what's happening as far as the weather
is concerned today and indeed for the
weekend it's friday yay here's nas good
morning
good morning good morning well big
temperature drop k for northern areas of
the uk today where it will be rather
cloudy and
wet further south warmer but with some
heavy showers
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning a big temperature drop
across northern parts of the uk for
today mainly around parts of scotland
and northeast england where it's going
to be cloudy
windy cool and wet in fact this morning
there are spells of rain across southern
parts of scotland east and scotland too
and areas of northern england also
showers
across many parts of england and wales
but
it is also mainly dry across ireland
northern ireland
and western parts of scotland now going
into this afternoon and we'll see most
that rain clear away eastwards
but it will continue across eastern
scotland southern scotland northern
england
and it will be rather windy across these
areas it's going to be a much colder day
compared
to yesterday that's due to northerly
winds as well bringing through that cool
airflow but
still warm and actually quite humid
across parts of england and wales
where there will be brighter sunny
spells developing but also the risk of
some showers across wales the midlands
central and eastern england
mostly dry for island and northern
ireland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this morning we bring you proof as if it
was needed that dogs really are
your best friend ambulance crews filmed
these pictures as they took a woman
to hospital in the turkish capital of
istanbul
her golden retriever wanted to ride with
her to the hospital it wasn't allowed
into the ambulance look what he did
look what he did determined not to be
defeated he followed her all the way
to the front door of the hospital
coming up in just a short time i will be
joined by the former chief medical
officer dame sally davis to discuss
prevention
of future pandemics
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello again you're watching the
breakfast program here on sky friday
morning the transport secretary has
warned tourists to be ready for
future and further changes to
international travel restrictions
when planning their holidays malta the
balearic islands and a number of
caribbean destinations such as barbados
have been put on a green watch list
which the government says means
they're at risk of switching to amber
grant shaps told this program
anyone going overseas needed to be
prepared for the rules
to change again whoever is booking um to
go anywhere
this summer at all you know travel
insurance
making sure your flights are changeable
and making sure the accommodations
change but all those things
are going to be very very important this
particular year and i think
you know people need to weigh up whether
that is going to be
work for them or not yeah because i mean
we saw what happened with portugal
though didn't we and that was on the
green
liz the watch list and that's flipped uh
in a heartbeat so that my question again
is
would you book a holiday for your family
to one of the balearic islands at the
moment given that it's on a watch list
yeah so actually they were just on the
green list and the reason we've
introduced the using this watchlist
category is to give people a bit more
visibility
uh over it if we think things might move
uh quicker
um so sadly i don't think i've got time
at the moment to
take a holiday um but you know if people
are in a situation where uh from next
week from next wednesday thursday
they wanted to get away then this these
are the places
where you can go for the purposes of
holiday of course being aware of all the
caveats rob that means
having the back of your mind what
happened in portugal yeah and the
difficulty is i think while the
government say this is about
transparency about giving people
uh warning and about shifting it
essentially to saying look you need to
make your own choices
i think people may think well if the
minister won't tell me whether he would
book a holiday in these circumstances
what am i supposed to do and then i
think the problem for business as well
is what they wanted to see yesterday was
some confidence injected back in the
market after an absolutely dire 15
months
and i think they've kind of gone some of
the way and said look you can go here
but then they've pulled back so i think
business will be asking this morning
and querying whether this really injects
the confidence into the industry that
they say they need matt hancock
yeah i think questions this morning
about a non-executive director who works
in the department
of health and social care this is gina
colladangelo now she took up this role
as non-executive director in september
2020.
we understand this is a paid role uh and
on the government website
it talks about her background in
marketing and communications at oliver
bonus the um
high street lifestyle her husband uh
store her husband
is very senior i think founded that as
well
now she went to university around the
same time as matt hancock studied the
same
topic there has been allegations in
newspapers before that they are
friends they knew each other from
university i think the precise nature of
how she was appointed to that job is
coming
under the microscope this morning when
you asked the transport secretary about
it he insisted everything was done by
the book
in terms of rules anyone who's been
appointed has to go through an
incredibly rigorous process in
in government um so whatever the rules
are the rules will have to be followed
there are no
shortcutting uh that is anyone who's had
anything to do with the
appointment system in the civil service
knows uh there
are very strict uh rules in place
yeah i mean the we spoke to the
department of health this morning they
said this appointment was made in the
usual way and followed
correct procedure what exactly also some
time ago
what is that procedure so it depends on
the
specific role but people have to go
through usually an
interview process which involves an
independent panel
recommendations are then made to
ministers
depending on the type of role uh you'll
get a
something called appointable or
non-appointable uh list and then you
make a
decision uh based on the qualifications
of the uh individual
so i don't think um i think it's a bit
of a red herring in in in this case i
think it's really a personal
story and it's not i don't intend to
comment on somebody else's
personal life now while gina
collidangelo was appointed in september
last year to this non-executive
directorship role
uh the overall department uh she has
been seen with matt hancock at
interviews and around parliament since
before that and if you look back at
a register of interests for research
assistants and members secretaries
she is listed under her married name
from february last year with the sponsor
on that database being matt hancock
as well so we've sent a number of
questions to the department of health
and social care this morning asking what
her precise responsibilities
were in the department and how she came
to be appointed prior to september 2020
and what her job was there
as yet we haven't got any detailed
answers though and she does have triple
a access to the building across the road
doesn't she
westminster so actually the most recent
register of um
interests for member secretaries and
research assistants doesn't list her
name but in february 2020 she is listed
under that
and that register generally is for pass
holders so i think it's unclear at the
moment whether she has
full parliamentary pass access but
certainly in february 2020 there was
involvement um there with the department
and directly the sponsor was the health
secretary
okay um lots to think about thanks very
much indeed thank you
uh the public inquiry into the covid
pandemic let's talk about that the
government's planning for a major
outbreak will be thoroughly examined but
countries around the world were caught
out by covert and now trinity college at
the university of cambridge
wants to fund projects which help to
identify and respond to emerging
diseases which could be the next
pandemic i should say the trinity
challenge was launched by england's
former chief medical officer dame sally
davis and she is with us now damn sally
it's lovely to see you thanks so much
indeed i suppose
my viewers this morning would think well
why don't we do that already
well we have systems in place but the
who did point out that the world was
unprepared
and what i and friends as this
pandemic unfolded thought was
that a lot of data that would help us
identify
respond and recover from pandemics
better
is held by the private sector behavioral
data
are we moving around are we spending
money our attitudes
meanwhile data science has moved on
immensely and many of the very best
are in the private sector so we set out
nine months ago
launching a charity with colleagues
to bring together a collaboration of
private sector
many of the data companies and insurance
companies from around the world
with top academics from around the world
to try and see
if by launching a public challenge we
could bring together
innovative minds with this data that's
already collected
to do these things and do it better
and this afternoon i'm going to open the
envelopes and announce the winners
from our pledged 5.7 million pound pot
and i can tell you the finalists are so
exciting
they will be helping the world go
forward
in what way can you give us any clues
well i can tell you some of the things
in the finalists they bring
in how to use in southeast
asia farmers as disease detectives
using things like blockchain to make
sure that as vaccines are rolled out
around the world
they we know where they are they're not
wasted they're not spoiled
using data on behaviors to see
whether people are vaccine hesitant and
what messages work with what communities
so a real variety of things and i have
to thank
our 42 members who have really helped
the academics and the
data companies in taking this forward oh
i can't wait to hear more about that
southeast
asia farmer detectives that sounds
fascinating stuff
um talk to me about why you think at the
capitol
doesn't have enough uptake on people
being vaccinated
well uh we've always had lower levels
of vaccination in london and it is to do
with
people being more deprived
um we need to get to them and talk to
them in different ways and the best
people to talk
to them are their own community and
interestingly
the church has been reaching out to
other faiths
and faith leaders have done a very good
job our public health colleagues
in london in those boroughs know what
needs doing and they
are working with the communities but you
have to do it community
building up you can't just do it from
organizing and admonishing from the top
okay this is about belief
now we know the health benefits of
double jab but what should be the social
benefits in your opinion
um i thought i was talking about
innovative science and science coming to
the rescue of society
um i think there should be some social
well there are some social benefits
those of us of my age who've got
both feel able to follow the government
guidelines and
meet people in the garden and outside i
have to say
that for all the double jab gives you a
lot of protection
it isn't total protection so we have to
go on washing our hands social
distancing
i think the evidence on mask wearing is
very strong
so i'm being very careful and i'm going
to go on being very careful
so you're going to carry on wearing your
mask even though we had some ministers
actually on the show who said that they
won't
uh do that it's a personal choice from
the 19th of july as we know
given what we know now and the research
that's been done and the event that you
will be unveiling
the winners of later on today do you
think that we
could ever find ourselves in the same
position again where a global pandemic
brings the net the world to its knees
of course we could and that's why i've
launched the trinity challenge we need
to prepare
better we need to use another example
from our finalists is sensors of sewage
and of air that can pick up pathogens
and then
wireless the results to a distance so
you can put them in poor communities we
really have to think about how we put in
place surveillance
and how how and the government led on
this through the g7
we get that hundred days from the
genomic sequence
to having a vaccine we've made great
strides
we've got a lot more to do which i mean
if you're looking back because
2020 hindsight is a wonderful thing
isn't it
what one thing could we have done
differently to have protected
our communities sooner
i expect the investigation will sort
that one out but personally i would have
gone for masks
earlier and i will go for a mask myself
longer okay and just while i've got you
i know
that what you came on to talk about and
hopefully you agree that we've we've
talked about that in some detail but
i know that you previously uh campaigned
uh
heavily for a crackdown on uh junk food
ads
um we're not hearing that the government
plans to ban the ads before 9 pm
are you chalking that up as a victory
i never see things as a victory for me
but it is a victory for the country
that at long last we're learning there
is no magic bullet
to solve obesity and yet we've got to
solve it
obesity gives you inflammation and they
were the people
who were most at risk of dying along
with people with other comorbidities
we've got to do it and i'm so pleased
we're making movements
uh just before you go damn sally how are
we going to learn more about
uh this afternoon's events did you will
you have a gold envelope and open it how
does that work
absolutely we're having an awards
ceremony do
uh go on to our website
thetrinitychallenge.org and watch
and you'll see the great winners they
are
so exciting well i really hope that
we'll be able to have some of them on
the programme next week but for now damn
sally it's lovely to talk to you thank
you
thanks a lot thank you like that
thumbs up quick look at the sport for
you now here's rob hi rob good morning
good morning to uk england's qriket is
missing a few big players but another
victory last night let's have a look at
some of the best of the action shall we
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
this is perhaps the most iconic sporting
image
of the 20th century tommy smith on top
of the podium and john
carlos on the right raising their fists
to protest against
racial injustice at the 1968 olympics
the gesture during the medal ceremony
changed their lives
this is the inside story of division the
fight for equality
and redemption
it was a joyous occasion for me after
the races were over
i felt like now i'm here to get busy to
do what i came to the games to do
i was extremely proud of these
courageous and committed athletes
it was a damn gutsy thing to do nobody
had any idea was going to follow but
nobody thought good things were going to
happen
they felt that we was a cancer to
society you might say
throughout the 1960s and leading up to
the 1968 olympics
many sportsmen and women in the usa were
grappling with how to reflect
social and political injustices for john
carlos and tommy
smith october 16th 1968
would become the day they chose to make
a statement
and send a message even in the context
of the entire 20th century
1968 was a turbulent year
the prague spring in the former
czechoslovakia the tet
offensive a turning point of the vietnam
war
student killings in orangeburg south
carolina by police
martin luther king jr's assassination
senator bobby kennedy brother of
president john f kennedy
is murdered dozens are killed protesting
in mexico city
10 days before the olympics begin and
then
on october 12th the games themselves
begin
this moment this image almost
never happened well i actually wanted to
boycott but you know personally i wanted
to boycott
uh committed to getting 100 million
people 20
more active by 2025.
[Music]
former chancellor george osborne is to
become the next
chair of the british museum he says he's
thrilled
that he'll take the job at a time when
the museum is coming under increasing
pressure to return hundreds of artifacts
to countries including greece
and nigeria talking about it in more
detail should be jeffrey robertson qc
who wants to describe the trustees
of the british museum as the world's
largest receivers of stolen property and
jacob reynolds from the academy of ideas
and the organizer of debating matters
hello t-bo thank you for joining us on
the program
this morning let's go to you uh first
jeffrey
robertson qc if we may what should he be
returning as soon as he
takes office in your opinion
good morning kay i think you should be
returning
those items of cultural heritage
that have been stolen in colonial wars
often with
a killing of men women and children
but deny the inspiration to
future generations of the great artists
who
lived and worked in their country now i
would begin
with the parthenon marbles which were
ripped off the temple walls of the
parthenon by
lord elgin's workman after he had paid
enormous bribes to the turkish officials
who should have been
stopping him they belong to greece and
there's a beautiful museum
beneath the parthenon itself where they
could be seen
this greatest wonder of the ancient
world that is still
to a large extent extent uh it can be
seen
under the blue attic sky where it
belongs
and not in the gloomy bloomsbury gallery
to which
half of it has been consigned so that
would be a great
start and it would be i think applauded
around the world then you have of course
the banyan bronzes
those extraordinary pieces of art which
were
looted by the british army in 1897 they
killed the men
women and children they then took them
back and they were sold
around the world president macron has
ordered the french galleries that
exhibit them to send them back
to nigeria and it's rather embarrassing
to be
led in morality by the french so
there are items like that but he should
keep uh
the rosetta stone which egypt wants
because the marble of the rosetta stone
that's
deciphering the key to an ancient
language
was done in the british museum when it
was there
okay so uh it should keep that okay lots
to go out there jacob
uh we should return uh most it was
certainly uh to nigeria should
we return the uh benin bronzes to
nigeria
and we should return the elgin marbles
to greece
yeah though i think nobody denies that
these uh artifacts have
the checkered histories but the demands
to return them
are i think quite damaging to an
important idea and an important ideal
which inspires visitors of these museums
in their millions
every year which is that these aren't
the parochial achievements of
particular cultures or particular people
in particular places
but these tell a part of the story of
the achievements of
humankind as such and that's how those
these artifacts can currently
be appreciated and the demands to return
them secondly
these demands i think often have a lot
more to do with
offering opportunities for western uh
political and cultural elites to engage
in
acts of moral ground standing rather
than being
particularly interested in the artifacts
or the places to which they go so i'm
much i much prefer to see them in
these kind of like world museums rather
than
trying to pigeonhole them as either
political footballs or
as just parochial elements only belong
to one particular people
jeffrey robertson casey well jake
jacob's great idea
is called colonialism it's called
finders keepers steelers keepers it
is the 19th century idea
of the kind of cult museum which has
shows the superiority of the west with a
smorgasbord of this and that
the greater idea is the idea of justice
justice to people who were looted and
plundered
in the 19th century that idea
is that the great works of art can be
appreciated
not as a bit or a piece of some
western triumphalist museum but as
with others of its kind together
with the great achievement that you
could see if the parthenon
marbles not the elven marbles the
parthenon marbles were reunited
okay let's jacob come in there
yeah i mean i i think it's obviously
very easy and very i'm tempting to
engage in sort of sweeping statements
like
referring to people who appreciate these
elements of world culture as
as being tainted by colonialism and that
says i think a lot more about
the people who want to return these
artifacts and it's a great opportunity
for
uh with all respect to the qc a great
opportunity for people to engage in
this kind of moral grandstanding rather
than drawing attention to
the either the real problems that exist
in countries where these
artifacts might be returned to or in
this case appreciating these
as as the cultural treasures that they
are your grandstanding jeffrey robertson
appreciation in
athens uh beneath the blue attic sky
seeing the parthenon marbles reunited
because it is the greatest wonder of the
ancient world everyone
millions would come to athens to see
them
whereas in the british museum they're
just
a bit and a piece on the way to the
egyptian mummies and the
other attractions of the museum that
jacob come in there
yeah i i think that the there's an
element of
a kind of dismissal of the people who go
as i say in their millions through these
museums no i'm one of them members
checking them when they see them in a
particular context whereas
i think the great thing about these
museums is they offer an opportunity to
tell a really rich and exciting human
story about
the achievements of human culture as a
whole sadly we're out of
uh time and hopefully you'll come back
and talk to us about it in more detail
when george osborne takes over at the
british museum thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you
you haven't thought about that had you
there you go uh quick look at the
weather i bet you thought about that for
the weekend
as has nas good morning naz good morning
looking pretty wet out there for today
quite cold in the north too
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so for today we are going
to see a big drop in temperatures for
northern areas of the uk it's going to
be a wet one this afternoon
across southern and eastern parts of
scotland particularly eastern scotland
and northern parts of england and wales
showers developing elsewhere in the
south where it will be brighter and
warmer but
mostly fine today for ireland and
northern ireland